this episode brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block pizza at 1811
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles they got
all kind of fancy hitters they're the
Frenchie the deep cheese and the Venice
if you got some room in your mouth for
something else
consider gray block I'm gonna do my
favorite Lee Corso impersonation right
now and I'm gonna pick LSU out of that
Death Valley right there you can see
that you can see this dome cover I have
right here and this is from hood hat USA
they have that college football
collection that is out enjoy your
college football squad this year they
have one that says jordan-hare for you
Auburn Tiger fans hood hat you got to
represent your hood you know it's your
team colors but it's your hood they have
the grove for Ole Miss they have coral
god bless for you they got big house for
Ohio State they got Casa Oh big house
for sorry Michigan and they have the
horseshoe for Ohio State they also have
Grand Concourse for the Yankees and and
Three Rivers for all you buckos fans in
the major leagues follow them on
Instagram at hood hat
USA and visit hood had come with the
code hood USA h oo d USA for 20% off
that's promo code hood USA at Hood hat
come for 20% off get that hat up I'm
letting you know my dates right now
September 14th and 15th I'll be at
Zanies in Nashville ah that might be
sold-out September 20th through the 24th
just for laughs and Toronto October 4th
through the 6th comedy zone in Charlotte
North Carolina those are on the calendar
as well I'll be in Chicago this weekend
or next weekend my bad
I want to tell you right now about a
very sleek item it's sometimes you have
all thick pants and sometimes you just
have aa panty sometime you just put a
panty on your legs or on somebody else's
legs even somebody who's you know
somebody who's alive and that's what I
want to talk to you about a panty for
your phone you know
and that's the minimal case M in ml case
it's the world's thinnest case it is
thin thin thin think about something
really really thin that's what it is
it's almost like a breath mint strip
just wrapped around your phone it is
0.001 inches thick and it showcases the
beauty of your phone it's so thin you
can't even imagine that now if you drop
your phone or something this thing's not
I mean it's not that holder you know
it's not that naughty you know that
naughty daughter that's just gonna grip
onto your thing but it's gonna be that
sleek fancy if you're taking your phone
to the prom then you might want to have
it in that minimal case it's available
for all major phones including iPhone
x87 pixel to Galaxy Note 8 and galaxy s
9 plus and there's a hundred percent
money-back guarantee if you are unhappy
for whatever reason they will reef where
they will re fund the purchase of the
case and no need to even send back the
case there you go you have nothing to
lose here and of course you can get a
discount by using the code théo go to m
in ml case calm and use code theo for
15% off so that's 15% off something
that's already minimal i mean there's
almost nothing even there go to m in ml
case comm for 15% off to get the
sleekest leanness I mean you were
talking this thing you could almost just
breathe real real Hardy on your phone
and it would be a set SS sleek I mean
this is if your phone is like just
having like a little kind of a condom
for your phone MN ml case comm he has a
new book available for pre-order right
now called the dichotomy of leadership
he's a host of Jaakko podcast you can
find him on social media at jaco will
link it is the retired navy seal a man
that turns wanderers into warriors
mr. Jocko
[Music]
to prepare for the day job now I got up
I got up actually this morning no I got
about 4:15 just to see what that would
feel like how'd it feel
it felt inspiring and then by about
state of club off maybe four fifty five
and then it felt kind of scary you know
I felt like I maybe had some sugar
issues and had to lay back down yeah
yeah I got up early this morning to
thank you know yeah do you on the
morning from you get up and you have
that do you have that moment in your
head where you don't feel like it
anymore I know that some of that goes
away when you repeatedly drive through
that moment do you still have that
sometimes sure sure and what do you do
go anywhere just go just go anyways just
keep it cruising yeah that's it take
action next foot yeah a lot of times
people say you know how do you get up
early in the morning and I say set your
alarm clock and get out of bed when it
goes off yeah that's what you do right
do you ever uh or are there days or
moments or the special times when you
let yourself you know that the
tomorrow's a day for luxury tomorrow's a
day to relax not relax not really yeah
not really cuz I've got a lot of stuff I
got to do right you know things you have
a lot of business a lot of stuff going
on yeah and just at the end of a day
where you took a luxury day is called a
luxury days I what you said I'll say
that okay so let's say you take a luxury
day okay right CEO takes a luxury do
okay at the end of that day how do you
feel right I feel like I need a gear
backup yeah well when I get to the end
of that day I just feel like I just
wasted a day of my life ransom I feel
like right you know so there's no luxury
days happen over here on my side okay
we're gonna keep it real over here
okay this I'll let you handle the luxury
scenarios I think I'd like to have less
luxury days in my life though maybe
that'll be one of my coming goals you
know I was thinking the other day are
there I was listening to some past
podcast you've had with Joe Rogan Tim
Ferriss
and are there things when you get into
combat when you get into a war type
scenario that that you that you think
you would be totally prepared for and
then there's something that breaks a man
at that moment that they have no point
to know before that
that they wouldn't be able to handle
they could do all the training they
could do everything they could do all
the preparation all the you know the the
you know simulation all of that but at
that moment there's something inside of
them and it's not gonna knock against
them but there's something they can't
handle yeah yeah for sure I mean so what
it is the big difference is someone's
going to try and kill you and you could
die and so some people have a real hard
time with that and so occasionally
you'll see a guy that doesn't want to be
in that situation where they can get
killed and and what is your
responsibility at that point like as a
leader like if you see something like
that happen are you able to notice kind
of that now like yeah the other thing
that can happen is as guys put
themselves and their lives at risk over
and over and over again eventually they
can get they can get worn down you know
combat fatigue and so as they get worn
down that's where the responsibility of
the leader is to try and recognize that
and then pull them off the frontlines to
the best of your ability the way I was
described to people especially when I'm
talking to the young leaders that are
out there that are that are that are
leading these men into combat is when
you see that it's like it's like having
a check engine light on the car right
mm-hmm if you take that car in for
service yeah you can put more oil in it
or whatever and it'll be fine but if you
keep running that engine at a hard pace
it's gonna it's gonna blow out the
engine and it'll be ruined right so you
got a as a leader you got to look and
recognize hey okay this guy's had a
little bit too much right now I need to
pull him off the front lines and you
don't you don't say I don't I wouldn't
say to you hey Thiel I can see you've
had too much I'm gonna pull you off the
front lines because your ego would get
involved and you'd say no no I'm good to
go when the reality is you need you need
a break but I might say hey Theo I got
this logistics run that needs to be made
back to the back to the rear can you
make sure you go do that for me in that
way I want to make sure we get this this
and this all squared away and I know
you're the guy I trust to get it done
and you'd be like yeah cool and then you
go back three or you pick up whatever
you need to pick up maybe you catch a
movie maybe you have a little feel
luxury day back there in the rear and
you get you know you get your you get
your mindset right again cuz guys do
break and it's it's
the responsibility leader to try and
prevent that and you know it's it's a
really horrible thing you know I just
did a podcast on my podcast and in World
War one the British I don't know if you
know anything about world war one but
world war one was absolutely heinous it
was a heinous war all wars are pretty
damn heinous but that kind of takes the
top spot as just horrible situations
where these guys are getting killed by
the by the tens of thousands right I saw
Dunkirk that's the only thing I saw in I
don't even know if that's from that war
yeah I I haven't seen that movie but in
World War one guys are in trenches and
you're going to charge another trench
against machine guns and they're getting
mowed down and there was no real you
don't really have any say as even as a
frontline leader was like okay at six
o'clock tomorrow morning you're gonna
get up with your platoon and you're
gonna charge this this other trench and
guys we just get killed and then you had
gas on top of that it was just a
nightmare and the British during that
war they executed about 350 people of
which about 300 of those were for
cowardice what they called cowardice Wow
now you can go on YouTube and you can
check out shell-shocked World War one
shell-shocked you see it's one of the
saddest things that I've seen in my life
as these guys are so because they're
getting bombarded with shells and an
artillery and mortars for for months and
months and months and months on end and
eventually their mind just couldn't take
it and different people have different
levels of what they can take and this
doesn't mean they're a bad person
doesn't mean they're a coward it means
that they took as much as they could and
they couldn't take it anymore and these
guys would literally shake this one
guy's he his wife gets a letter and she
doesn't recognize the handwriting and
it's because he's in hospital he has to
have a nurse write files he can't hold a
pencil to write to his wife and this
particular guy he ends up getting
executed shot at dawn which is what they
did with these guys about 300 of them
and eventually the British government
admitted and said hey we were wrong and
we did the wrong thing but that's a
situation where if you had these guys
who you see that they're breaking you
get
off the front line you get him some rest
and relaxation and some luxury Theo
style you get you get them in that
mindset where they can relax and then
eventually they'll build back up and
they'll be ready to go back to the front
again hopefully and maybe they won't but
there's a good chance that they will so
that's that's definitely something that
a leader needs thinks needs to think
about and it's also something that you
as a human being need to think about
right guys can push themselves so hard
that eventually they they need it they
need a break you know and you have to
monitor a lot of that it's hard in every
but you have to monitor a lot of that
with ego cuz I'm sure you know with a
lot of bravado sometimes the ego can
probably get involved you know and with
a lot of these men trying to I mean
there's a lot of tough men that you work
yeah just like I was just giving you
crap when we walked in here I'm just
acting like I'm all hard and never take
a day off you know and you're kind of
like chuckling but that's what's that
that's me just kind of playing my ego
out hey I'm never gonna Bret never gonna
rest never gonna take a break I'm just
having fun yeah I've got to recognize
hey if I if I get to a point where my
mind is overwhelmed and I need to take a
luxury day with Theo von and that's what
it is what's um is there is it hard to
manage sometimes like do you see guys
that are almost like or even in your own
life have you noticed like as you become
more of a you know I heard you talking
on I think it was the first time that
you were on Joe or one of the times
you're on Joe Rogan's podcast about
being a and I love how Joe Rogan's
podcast has become almost like our
library in America in a lot of ways like
if it in a neat way because it's an
honest you know I saw it like I know
it's a real it's a you know it's a it's
something like that I know occurred it's
not just like a statement by somebody
that I've heard that I wrote that's that
I read it's like okay I saw this happen
I know that this is the real occurrence
but yeah you and you actually saw it me
it's yes the words coming out of my
mouth
yeah yeah I think it's huge authenticity
Jordan Peterson was talking about this
about how people are flocking to podcast
because people are just dying for
authenticity they just want things that
are real but do you notice in your own
life like I mean I've noticed even that
like our pop as our podcast has grown
and it's grown
I mean it's grown like three times and
this year I think you know and it's it's
been a blessing and it's also been a lot
of pressure and it's also like I start
to worry about my own ego you know I
start to worry about well how is
is gonna start to infect me how do I
make sure that you know I'm the same
person that started the podcast I want
to grow and expand but how do I not you
know it's easy to give in to becoming
the idea of yourself you know have you
started a battle with any of that or
seen some of that or like notice those
things start to flare up in your own
life I'm not accusing you I'm just
curious about no I I hear where you're
coming from and you can see where that
can definitely happen for me I think
I've been surrounded by so many guys
that are way better than me that it's
it's really challenging for me to try
and think I'm anything yeah I've been
surrounded by heroes and guys that have
sacrificed and done so much that for me
to be doing what I'm doing is just I'm
just sitting over here trying to get by
and you know I always talk about the
fact that what one thing that is good
about podcasts is hey it's just me
sitting in a room like even what you
have here this setup is is pretty
extravagant compared to me I have me and
my the guy that does a podcast with me
echo and it's two microphones and we're
in a little room a black room that's it
and that's not the interrogation all
that I like yeah it is kind of like
interrogation and it's sort of like an
interrogation of myself because when
you're again another thing I do in my
podcast all the time is I I read books
or excerpts of books from guys that have
been through insane situations in combat
and so you can't even can't even put it
I can't even put a finger to these guys
and what they've done so yeah it's it's
really easy to stay humble when you see
what other people are doing and have
done yeah I guess it's really easy to
stay humble I guess when you're yeah
when you're in that when you win the
world's one of the worlds that you work
in has so much sacrifice in it which one
of the what's a sacrifice that you in my
channel you saw like on the battlefield
or something you saw up there you know I
mean when we my last deployment to Iraq
the the amount of sacrifice that we saw
was was incredible and it was every
single day there was guys that were I
mean soldiers and Marines that were
getting wounded and killed and you know
we lost some of our guys and and
I mean it's another level it's another
level you know when people talk about
sacrifice even you know you kind of hear
people talking about you got to make
sacrifice to get to get ahead or you got
to make sacrifice to get where you want
to be this is just another level of
sacrifice when guys are risking their
lives for for each other
and for what they believe in and when
you see in most these days there's a lot
of pressure I feel like like even
recently even having the American flag I
almost feel like it's some people look
down upon upon it in some ways like it's
like you know it's almost become a
symbol of like conservatism sometimes in
America and do you feel like that
patriotism has gotten any different over
your tenure in the military have you
seen that kind of change like what it
means to like be a patriot is it just
about the flag is it about the country
like have you seen any like has that
adjusted for you kind of over the time
my viewpoints haven't really adjusted
other than that when you travel around
the world and you see repressed nations
and oppressed nations and oppressed
people it makes you very very grateful
to live in a place where you can pretty
much do whatever you want I mean it's an
incredible it's incredible blessing to
be in a country like America where you
can like I said you can pretty much do
whatever you want as not as long as
you're not hurting other people yeah you
can kind of do whatever you want here
and so you does that make you more
patriotic in a way it does but you know
for me my level of patriotism hasn't
really changed since since I've been in
or other than to say yeah I've seen
other parts of world and yeah I've seen
people that have are willing to
sacrifice their lives for for the
freedom that we have and that's
something that I think about every
single day I think about that is there a
sense when you're in like a when you're
in a battle environment you know and I
know you had the experience where you
know one of you a lot of the experience
you've talked out of the Ramadi when you
guys were now were you guys taking oh
you guys expunging Isis from the city or
were you there and keeping Isis out so
first of all it was it was 2006 so they
didn't start use
the name Isis until about 2007 2008 is
when they started to gain power at this
time it was al Qaeda in Iraq that was
the the group and yes they were
insurgents and yes they were embedded
inside the city the city had about a
population of about 400,000 normal Iraqi
civilians just normal people that wanted
to live their lives and embedded in
those people and intertwined and those
people as a bunch of really evil really
evil subhuman just insurgent terrorists
that wanted to get power for themselves
and we're willing to do anything to get
there including massacre torture rape
murder the local populace and did you
realize that Eagle that that evil
existed at those levels like who did did
did did that experience redefine kind of
your level for evil or chaos I would say
both my deployments I mean on my first
deployment I remember going into a room
where Saddam had done torture and like
there was hooks on the wall and like big
hooks where you'd hang meat I mean it
was like really when you walked in there
it felt haunted uh I don't know if I
believe in ghosts or whatever but if I
that must be sort of what ghosts feel
like you know walk in this room where
you know people had been tortured and
killed and brutally murdered and I am
you kind of feel that I met a lot of
pain which almost scare your spirit out
of your body here it's just sitting
there next to you almost so when you see
that yeah you start to feel I mean you
definitely know that that there's evil
in the world for sure
and does that Rhian spire your support
your fear does that then like once you
get to that point because you I'm sure
as you build up you know your battle
experience in your battle your your
abilities to go fight in your
preparation and then you get there does
that then change like oh wow we really
are fighting something I knew I knew and
my guys knew that we were going to get
something that's I mean you know you can
look at you look at what the insurgents
are doing it and really when you got to
see Isis that's one thing that was
interesting is once Isis started sort of
social media broadcast
what they were doing yeah and I don't
know if they thought it would help them
or whatever but it didn't help them you
know people started I mean it helped if
you were sick twisted person you saw
Isis doing that you go oh cool I'm gonna
go to join Isis but most rational normal
civilized human beings looked at what
they were doing and just said this is
horrible and these people need to be
destroyed and they've done I mean the
the the military has done a great job of
eliminating Isis it hasn't really gotten
a lot of press but uh it's been
incredible there was about 40,000 Isis
and now there's I don't know maybe 500
left
so from forty thousand five hundred
that's that's pretty pretty dominating
victory and there like I said there
hasn't been much press about it and I
don't know if the press hasn't come
because of because of the current
president and people don't want to say
hey this guy did it or if it's because
it wasn't just Americans that did it was
the the Iraqis did a lot of the fighting
and so maybe people weren't that
concerned about it because the Iraqis or
maybe you know once once it's not oh
maybe it's less of a news story when
it's not up close and personal which is
like the videos they were sending out
which would always get out of air time
I'm not sure yeah yeah no I think
there's definitely it feels like to me
that there's something out there where
yeah they don't even want to look at
that war is even a thing that happens or
that fighting is even a thing that
happens anymore you know it's almost
like it's um like it's taboo or
something even though it's necessary do
you feel sometimes in your blood like
that will have to be at war again well
we're at war right now yeah so it's not
even again look we're in a state of war
right now and so when you say that what
does that mean like so for a regular
American like me that goes through their
day what types of things are going on in
the background kind of that we don't
realize well I mean there's still Isis
that's left there's still other elements
of al Qaeda that are brewing up there's
people that are being trained that need
to be stopped
there's insurgent forces that are rising
up that need to get put down is there's
all kinds of things happening all the
time and it's it's going to be
continuing in that way for a long time
in my opinion and I know you and like
you you talk a lot about like you know
not wasting time when you wake up in the
morning or when you like
through a theme inside of your brain
that like your enemy is them your enemy
is like evil your enemy is wasting your
own time like do you have like kind of
an enemy in your head yeah I mean
especially when I was still in obviously
I had to I had a theme a big theme in my
head that you know I was gonna be
meeting some other guy on the
battlefield and it was gonna be who's
more prepared and so but now that I'm
not doing that anymore now I wake up in
the morning well first of all I never
stole people it's like when you wake up
in the morning don't think about
anything don't sit there and starts
thinking about rationalize words just
get up and do what you're supposed to
yeah just turn off your brain and go and
execute and just don't think cuz when
you start thinking you start making
things up and you start thinking about
luxury and all those things that you
could be doing in eggs yeah whatever
and so I just just stop all that just
get up and just do what you're supposed
to do but from a day-to-day basis I mean
you know the fact that I've got I've got
friends a lot of friends that aren't
here that don't get to live their lives
anymore that were killed and I want to
make sure that I'm taking advantage of
every minute and every second that I
have and live in a life that if they're
there watching me right now they're
thinking all right all right good jock
was getting after it yeah he's doing it
and you in America do you think we do a
lot of that or do you feel like the
average American we just don't realize
the luxury that we have I think it's a
little bit of both I think it's a little
bit of both there's there's definitely
people that you know I work at a
consulting company now and I work with
companies all over the place and there's
people in those companies that are just
getting after it in their own way and
they're building businesses and they're
growing businesses and they're taking
over market share and they're working
hard and they're raising their families
and they're doing great things I mean
it's it's awesome to see so there's
plenty of people like that in America
that I see on a day-to-day basis and and
when I work with the military still I
meet young you know people talk about
Millennials I meet kids that are 18 19
20 years old and man they're ready to
they're ready to do whatever they have
to do for for their job for their
country and it's awesome to say so
maybe the maybe the people that are more
negative get more press and the people
that are a little bit more positive they
don't they don't get as much press
when you see when you're having like an
experience in a battle right and you is
it almost sometimes become like a and
I'm not trying to equate says but it's
become like a video game experience to
like I'm trying to think of a way that
somebody like myself could could like is
there ever like a moment or you know a
half hour or four hours that break down
and you're like afterwards you're like
oh man I wish you two kind of played
that you know I wish I could play it
over that definitely happens yeah I mean
I don't really play video games right
but but when you look back and we always
would look back we'd always reflect when
we get done with an operation or get
done with an event that unfolds we
always look back at it and say what
could we have done better what could've
done different even if we won't went
well even if even it goes well we still
look at it and say hey what could we've
done better if it goes bad we definitely
break it down and try and figure out
what mistakes we made and how we can fix
them if somebody if you if you take a
casualty on the battlefield somebody
loses their life what is like the
protocol and that in that experience
what is that like well the first thing
you have to do is win the fight right
because that that's that's if you if you
take one casualty and you focus on that
well then you're gonna take more
casualties because their enemies still
trying to try to get you so what you do
is when you take a casualty you still
try and win the fight you try and make
sure you suppress the enemy fire you get
your troops in a situation where they
can defend themselves and then you can
start worrying about you know the
casualties is it when one of us a moment
like that happens is it scary or is it
sad like what is are you is there what
is that like it's both I mean I'll tell
you when you're going through these
situations it's you're you're doing what
you've been trained to do and that
becomes you know the focus of okay this
is what's going on here's what we're
going to do to to correct the situation
or try and handle the situation you got
to kind of put your emotions in check
for until until you have time later so
and and does it automatically kind of
happen that way most of the time like
your emotions are almost a luxury if you
will to have later on a guy that's been
well trained he's gonna he's gonna put
his little he's gonna put his emotions
aside Wow and put them in check and you
know that can be problematic of course
afterwards and if you put those emotions
away and you keep them away you don't
ever let him out then
can become problematic is and they can
start you up from the inside so at some
point you got a you know when you get
the time you got to take a step back and
you've got to you know let out the
emotions and and mourn the losses and
then once again when you get done with
that you can't dwell on that you can't
keep thinking about what the losses were
and you can't dwell in the past you know
and a lot of people ask me about when
they lose when they lose loved ones and
how do you get through it and that's
what I tell them like look you know in
America we don't have like a set
standard way of handling death right we
don't have a ritualistic way because
we're all from different cultures and
all different cultures handle things in
different ways but we've taken them all
and kind of mix them together and if
it'll mix them together we kind of lost
them I mean you look at other cultures
and it's like when someone dies you do
this for a day I do this for two days
you do this for another day and then you
move on right you go through these
little ceremonial things you sing this
song and you you know you you say this
prayer and then you do this ceremony and
then it's over yeah and in us we kind of
mill around a little we kind of mill
around and we don't really know what
protocol to follow so you know for me it
was like okay we got a I didn't really
think about this at the time but it's
like okay we're gonna we're gonna have a
ceremony you know we're gonna celebrate
the life we're gonna mourn the loss and
then we're gonna get back to work we're
gonna we're gonna move on right and when
I say move on that can sound cold and
callous and by no stretch of the
imagination do I mean like hey we're
gonna move on and forget about this no
but but we're not gonna dwell in the
past we're not gonna dwell on the fact
that we we lost one of our brothers
we're gonna we're gonna remember them
always but our best way of remembering
them is to move on is to live a good
life is to continue to execute the
mission you know that's one of the
things that you know for me it's like
when you know cuz we don't get trained
you don't get trained on what are you
doing one of your guys gets killed
there's no training for that no one can
really prepare you for that I think
especially when when I was coming up in
the in the SEAL Teams we hadn't been at
war for since Vietnam and so there
hadn't been a lot of guys killed and so
it was it wasn't like we were getting
experience from older guys that were
saying hey when you lose somebody this
is what you do this is the protocol and
so for me was sort of you know
when when when mark leaves the first
seal that got killed he was one of my
guys his incredible person when he got
killed like there is no training for
that and there was there was and I
didn't really know what to do and so for
me it was like okay we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna mourn we're gonna take
a couple days off we're gonna mourn and
then and I told my guys I'm like look
the only thing I know how to do the only
thing I know how to do is work this is
the only thing I know how to do cuz you
know I've been I was in the SEAL Teams
my whole adult life I don't even know
what else there is I was like the only
thing I know how to do is work and
that's what I'm gonna do and that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna go back to
work like Mark would want us to do we're
gonna lock unload our guns I wanna get
out there and when it do our missions
and and you know that's what we did
and again it's I know it might sound
callous and even saying it right now and
you know like mark you know here's a guy
that was yeah he was an absolute just a
warrior of a human but he was also a
hysterical guy he was a maniac guy he
was you know he was married he had a
beautiful wife and you know he was a he
was a real person and I always try and
remind you know everyone that these that
these warriors you know these so-called
warriors these soldiers these Marines he
steals these special operations guys
that everyone thinks they're these
warriors and that they're just warriors
that that there's a whole other side to
these guys and they're they're you know
usually just awesome people that happen
to have wanted to do something heroic
with their lives and they step into the
into the fray and so for me to say oh
we're just gonna move on again it's not
it's not like hey we're gonna forget
about this guy or but but the contrary
is we're always going to remember them
and the way we're gonna remember them is
by doing our job and doing the best we
can and in the life that we do have and
moving forward yeah not dwelling and
it's so funny I get stuck a lot of times
sometimes yeah I definitely noticed that
like I'm sober right so I you know been
sober for about two years and one of the
things that they taught me in the
beginning was just to take the next
right action like no matter what's going
on like no matter what you're thinking
especially because the devil can really
live in your head you know just to take
that neck does do whatever you have to
do next whatever is on your to-do list
do
that next thing and by the time he gets
even the next thing you only you're not
thinking about this now you're in motion
and an object in motion stays in motion
and then you usually start to piece
slowly piece your life together in
positive ways and then you get to the
end of the day one day and you're like
holy [ __ ]
I did five things today and then you
literally I remember that next day I
woke up a different person because for
so long I've just been dwelling in this
you know in my own fears and my you know
just sitting in my uncertainties and
just juggling like my my deficiencies
and just always just keeping so much of
the negativity kind of afloat or just
the uncertainty afloat and all I had to
do was just really physically take
action and the rest of me would kind of
follow it's amazing how your brain even
though your brain makes the decisions
your brain will follow your body
sometimes yeah the the two are
definitely connected there's no doubt
about it
and I always feel I always tell people
and you know when I heard you were
talking about Tim Ferriss when Tim
Ferriss was on my podcast and we were
talking about you know he went through
some serious depression he went through
contemplating suicide and planning
suicide Wow for himself and this is a
guy that was at Princeton University at
the time it wasn't like he was he was
not doing well in life I mean he was on
a great path and so one of the things
that he said is when when you complete
something long lines of when you can't
get out of your head get into your body
but it was like you know take go and do
something physical and so that's why I'm
you know I always tell people to hey if
you're if you're feeling whatever not
great go and do something go and do
going people go and work out go for a
run go for a swim go do something and do
some physical exertion because it lets
your mind just kind of turn off and stop
juggling all those insecurities that you
were just talking about because it's got
a juggle kettle bells or something else
instead yeah let your mind take a break
what kind of like say if you're gonna do
something cuz I fit I feel like you
don't probably even I feel like you
sleep kind of but like you're just like
you're also leg pressing while you're at
rest what kind of thing do you play with
like I feel like you have like is there
a get like I don't wanna say a game
because I don't want to seem offensive
but is there a board game or something
that you enjoy is there you know like
Stonehenge like what do you [ __ ] play
with for fun I feel
like isn't Stonehenge like what's those
rocks I know what that is but I don't go
like play with stone here look I had a
picture you like kind of playing with
something the yard I feel like it would
be like do we have the small stone head
in spinal tap Jacko's baby stone here
yeah does uh does jiu-jitsu count
yeah Jitsu is definitely jiu-jitsu is
definitely a place where you can turn
your brain off you can do it all the
time all you need is a training partner
and some mats and there's it's great
right now cause it's plenty of place to
train them yeah but yeah jiu-jitsu is
awesome to do have you had Eddie Bravo
come on your podcast yes I have not had
any Bravo come on my podcast yet it
would be super interesting to City that
would be it would be way fascinating I
don't know no I totally yeah I mean you
know yeah and the jiu-jitsu world but
yeah I mean I know him because of Joe
Rogan and I and I actually I actually
know him I mean yeah you know cuz he's
old-school jujitsu players him and I
were coming up around the same time
competing at the same old-school jujitsu
tournaments back in the day right and so
yeah yeah and you know he's he's always
been awesome
yeah cool to me I would love to see you
might need special forces to get him to
quiet down sometimes he gets a little
chatty but in a beautiful way though he
just I never met a man who's full of I
mean most people have nine pints of
blood or something I bet he's running on
eleven like that guy definitely
something else is in him you know he's a
special guy so so for a guy like who's
not you know a lot of guys feel regret
and I notice in my life that I feel
regret like I never served my country
right it's a thing they play you know
that kind of I think at the core of a
man somewhere it plagues us you know and
it's almost you feel ashamed to bring it
up because you don't want to use it as
like a pawn like whenever somebody has
served and it you know to try and equate
to that like oh I feel bad I didn't
serve you know but do you find that a
way that you know minute my age I'm 38
or that it you know her kind of
regularly statured physically that a way
that it can start to toughen themselves
up jiu-jitsu seems like a way that a lot
of men are finding like not only ways to
feel tough about themselves and feel
some self-confidence but to find like a
brotherhood in a way ya know just is a
great way the funny thing is is you just
mentioned like jujitsu makes you feel
for well actually do Jitsu makes you
feel humble especially when you start
cuz you're just gonna get choked out
you're gonna get tapped out by people
that are smaller than you and bye-bye
females that are smaller than you are
and and that stings
you know that's things and so jujitsu is
real humbling in the beginning and
that's just something you got a that you
got to get through but yeah you'll
you'll meet people when you train hard
with people you become closer with them
that's that's kind of what happens in
the military that's the general that's
the general concept of what occurs in
the military you take a bunch of people
that don't know each other that are all
different you start putting them through
hard training and they start to form a
bond and that's what the military is
that's why you end up with a bomb and
that bond the more hard stuff you do the
tighter that bond gets so when you go to
war with guys that that bond gets even
tighter when you got a really hard
sustained combat that bond gets even
tighter and so is jujitsu something that
is hard training and you it's humbling
because guess what in war you make
mistakes too and everyone sees them and
so that's what happens in jujitsu you
make mistakes everyone sees them you get
tapped out there's no there's no
question about it like there's no
mystery in jujitsu you got tapped out by
this guy that's it that's that's the way
it works and that means that guy just
beat you and there's no question about
it in combat the same thing happens you
make mistakes you're your element gets
surprised you you get ambushed you get
the the enemy maneuvers on you in a way
you didn't expect it catches you off
guard it's like yeah that's really
humbling and so there are elements of of
combat that are present in jiu-jitsu and
that's one of the reasons why I love
jujitsu so much yeah because now do you
love like do you find that over time
having served running gyms jiu-jitsu do
you like what is it that you is a combat
that you love is it competition have you
been able to kind of pinpoint like what
that dry like what that thing is sort of
yeah I would say there's like a whole
bunch of different level little levels
of what I like I like it I like
competition I like winning and oddly
enough I'd like losing like I like
getting pushed to a point where hey man
I I didn't I couldn't do it and that
doesn't there's this is a weird thing
that happens with you do too you take
someone that's never done digits before
yeah you say hey come and train and they
try it and they're gonna get crushed
and there's two reactions you can have
to that as a person right well I mean I
guess there's more than two but there's
two main ones that occur
some people say damn that was awesome I
can't believe that I got tapped out
right by a hundred and thirty pound
female right I'm gonna go back and learn
this stuff and some people say I can't
believe I got tapped out by a hundred
and thirty pound female I'm never gonna
get near that again because I hurts
their ego too much so that's pretty much
for me it was immediately
hey I want to make sure that that this
doesn't ever happen to me or that this
happens as little as possible because I
want me to learn as much as I can and
it's the same thing with you know it's
the same thing with combat like you want
to learn and you want to be as
proficient as possible and really I
think that's the way you should be with
life is like I'm gonna do as much as I
can as often as I can and learn as much
as I can and get the most out of this
little gig we got here for however many
years you got let's make something
happen do you do you miss war you miss
it you miss battle yeah yeah yeah like
you miss when you think about missing it
is it here's the thing is the
camaraderie what is it it's definitely
the camaraderie but but imagine imagine
that you feel had something going on in
your life that required every ounce of
energy and focus that you could possibly
muster it required all of that it
required all that focus and and the
consequence of you failing to to give
everything you got that consequence to
that would be possibly your death and
the death of your friends so you can't
you can't create that kind of focus any
other way I mean I I just don't know so
when you when you're in that and you get
to feel that and then you get the you
get the reward of knowing that you've
done your duty and and you've done the
best that you can you walk off the
battlefield and you gave everything you
got then it's it you definitely miss it
yeah do you find there are moments and I
can fatten that as you're saying that
like almost
as crazy as it sounds almost feel like
how amazing that would be to have
nothing else bothering you nothing
except the value of your own life and
the value of somebody else's life the
value of your friends is the is the
biggest value that's the biggest thing
that I was always concerned about like
my guys you know my guys concerned about
my guys yeah it's and it's it took me
about a month maybe two months after I
got home that when I woke up I woke up
and I would be like well you know for a
couple of seconds you're thinking cuz
you know when I was over there I was in
charge of a bunch of different guys and
so there was always guys operating in
the field there was guys out conducting
operations always so when you woke up
and went to see bu you were checking in
always wanting to know and and and you
always think well you know it's tonight
gonna be the night did you see as you
wake up you think up because my other
guys would know hey if something was
going on they'd come and get me if I was
asleep and it's not like I was sleeping
a lot but when I was asleep they'd come
and get me and say hey this is going on
or if a guy got wounded Hank I got
wounded or whatever and so you know you
know how it is when you first wake up
and you think oh is this a dream is
what's happening and so it took about
like a month a month or two before the
first thought that I had in the morning
wasn't a lot of weight or one of my guys
is one of my guys hurts one of my guys
killed that that took like a couple
months to get over that that thought but
again even that just there's a level of
there's a level of it's just focus man
it's just there's a level of focus that
you get into that and it's like is it me
on almost is it almost is it almost you
say you can't create it so it does it
almost feel so when you're we're on
human a new trainer when you're training
for a fight right we start training a
bunch of MMA fighters through the years
and as hard as you can train a guy in
the gym you can't you can't simulate
what's gonna feel like the night that
he's walking into you've been in the
UFC's yet no but Joe just helped me
yesterday I was talking on the phone he
said that
uh he would he offered to take me and
now I'm gonna forget people gonna hold
him to it
to the Poirier Diaz fight yeah so so
that's gonna be sick right and but you
can't simulate what's gonna be going
through Dustin Poirier mind when he's
gone or how hard Nate Diaz is gonna be
holding on to a move you know like you
just can't simulate that and it's the
same thing in combat as close as you can
try and get that mindset going you can't
simulate the exact same thing you just
can't do it you just it just can't do it
yeah and when so wait a minute do do
things get broad do over time being a
madam we often do things start to get
more narrow like in the sense where you
does it get you get used to it is that a
monthly is it amazing that that is a
muscle that somewhere inside of man that
get that you get used to you get used to
it I'll tell you the biggest thing for
me and and our training definitely
helped I don't want to make it sound
like because all right like our training
got us so close it's sort of the opening
question one of the earlier question you
asked me like is there someone that
breaks cuz they there's something you
can't simulate in training they've been
through all this hard training and they
still just say hey man I can't do this
yeah that happens but the training gets
you pretty close I mean the training
gets you to a point where you know the
first firefight I ever got and I was
like okay cool
I wasn't like I was like oh my god you
know I was just okay here's what's going
on
I see where the enemy is hey we need to
do this and start making my tactical
calls it's like real straightforward and
so the training can definitely get you
there and and something that I talk
about a lot is developing the ability to
detach from what's happening detach from
the chaos detached from the mayhem and
detach from your own emotions because if
you get wrapped up in your emotions
you're not making good decision right
right and I've heard a cowboy you know
cowboy Cerrone is he's a fighter yeah
yeah but I heard him talking when he
fights really well he said he feels like
he's behind like you talked a bit of he
feels like he's playing himself in a
video game and it's just he can watch
and he can see everything and that's
when you when you get that ability to
detach and take a step back that's very
powerful in the way you get that is by
putting yourself in pressure situations
or being put into pressure situations
where the only way to make good
decisions is to take a step back
not get all captured in some situation
and let things kind of you you you get
to a point where you can kind of see
things unfolding and I do that all the
time now Wow it's kind of crazy
you know before we I want to say one
more thing yes you you mentioned this
part and I don't want to leave it
hanging you mentioned this part about
like hey you know you feel guilty
because you haven't served and and I
hear that from a lot of people and and I
can't even imagine like if I didn't
serve I can't imagine how I would feel
about that but what I wanted to say is
you know it's first of all it's not for
everyone
yeah that's that's fine it's like not
every you don't need to be in the
military to serve and and the other
thing is like okay what can you do if
you didn't serve well there's a bunch of
things you can do and one of the best
things you can do is if you haven't
served is you go out and you try and
live a good life right you try and raise
a good family you try and build a good
business you try and you try and just be
a good person yeah because and and and
I'm not just saying that like uh I'm not
just saying it hey be a good person I'm
saying by doing good things you're an
American if I'm talking to people that
are from America right now if you're
building a business you're helping
America yeah if your ear be helping our
economy without a thriving economy in
this country the military doesn't
wouldn't even exist right so the one of
the best things you can do as a person's
go out and do your job really really
well go out and kick ass and be the best
you know whatever your job is and we
work like I said with with my consulting
company work with all different kinds
companies on that side guys on the front
line do manufacturing and doing
construction drill and oil I mean
whatever you're doing go out and kick
ass at that and make that your mission
and you are by doing that you're
literally building America and keeping
America strong so you're serving it's in
a weird way as you say that I'm thinking
you're serving America in a way you're
serving America by being a good person
by putting other people employed by
doing fair business ya know you're
serving this country it's a real thing
and I explain that to people all the
time you know explain out to people all
the time you know when I talk to
construction companies I'm like hey
you're literally building this country
that's that's actually what you're doing
Wow
when I talk to gas oil companies I say
you know you're
you're literally fueling this company
that's this country that's what you're
doing so and it goes with everything
with the software company hey you're
built you're employing how many thousand
people two thousand people that's what
you're doing all those people are able
to feed their kids and pay their
mortgage and save Raj and and that's
what it is so if you didn't serve it's
okay
like that's fine serve in another way
and one of the easiest ways to serve is
you go out and kick ass in the world I
like that man that's beautiful huh
that's cool yeah we try to do some
special stuff here you know we try to
treat single moms out to like a night
out when we're in a city yeah yeah
seeing that you do that that's awesome
it's pretty cool man were you raised by
both your parents I was yeah that's
awesome and do you feel like a lot of
your uh do you feel like a lot of your
your abilities do you notice that some
of them came from your mom and someone
came from your dad I don't know I don't
know it's kind of funny
so was your mom a tough lady you know my
mom and dad they were pretty normal and
to be quite honest with you smart I'll
give him that they're smart but they're
pretty normal now my my mom was an
English teacher mm-hmm and my dad was a
history teacher and so people when they
listen to my podcast because I'm always
talking about literature and history
that's kind of what I talk about a lot
well that's what it's based on but I'm
really talking about human nature that
that's that's what I'm really talking
about talking about my podcast about
human nature but it's human nature
through the lens of war and through the
lens of leadership and through the lens
of atrocities and horrible things that
happen because that's what reveals human
nature right when you're when you're out
with your friends and everything's going
cool you don't learn anything about your
friends when you're out with your
friends and there's a car accident oh
you definitely learn you learn that's
what you learned I was in a hell of a
turret got stalled right and you think
like okay there's nine people in
elevator this is at Mardi Gras this is
about probably maybe seven years ago and
when everyone is going up to like a
fancy party we were on the street
watching Endymion which is a big parade
down there next you know we're taking an
elevator up to a fancy party and the
elevator gets stalled we're in there for
two hours right by the second hour broke
people start to like one girl had broken
down and started crying
one dude like I came out of the closet
eating each other yeah like people like
but you start one guys start thinking
about starting a small business like you
some one guy literally had been
stringing on the other better doors so
like I think both of his arms came out
of socket like but you start to see
who's who and when when the pressure is
on that's interesting man I want to put
myself in more pressure situations
because you know I think I do as almost
as scary as it is I think I do want to
know more about myself and I do want to
kind of know who I am yeah so that's
well in reading these books and almost
all the books that I talk about in my
podcaster I either have people on there
that have been through these situations
or they're first-person accounts of guys
that were in war so that's what I do so
back to my parents so my my mom was an
English teacher my dad was a history
teacher I was a super rebellious kid I
didn't he I couldn't care less about any
of that never did any homework I was
kind of a maniac and so even you know my
parents are kind of like well I guess
you turned out pretty good but they
don't they don't jump and take a bunch
of credit for it because they don't feel
like it was them but you know certainly
I I was around them and so you know like
like my dad's really really a really
brilliant guy and so I'm thankful that
you know I maybe caught a fraction of
what my dad has for like my mom's you
know really smart too so do you feel
like you've made them pretty proud you
know the thing is I'm from New England
and and you don't you don't we don't do
that up there oh there is no there is no
like hey good job like they don't care
like work harder that's that's the whole
that's sort of the New England thing oh
you did this we don't care anymore
yeah that's pretty fascinating um there
was something you were just talking
about that I was thinking about about
what are ways that that men can test
themselves you think so
jiu-jitsu is one thing that's really
interesting you know where you can get
out and immediately learn like wow I
thought I was a badass because I had
this new necklace but also I just got
put into a [ __ ] hard scarf by some
you know 90 pound Vietnamese girl you
know so like who am i all of a sudden
you know are there other things that you
find that you are though that novices
and people who were you know new to kind
of testing their own spirit and their
own limits could do yeah I think there's
all kinds of things and I think that's
there's so many things like that right
now that that's why because people have
realized that they want so if you look
at the Spartan races the tough mudders
the CrossFit Games you got all these
things right all those things are
you're not doing those you're doing
those because you want to test yourself
yeah so I think there's all kinds of
different ways for guys and and females
to test themselves right now get out
there and and push hard and it feels
good you know we know it feels well you
might not know it feels good you but I
think the luxury feels good some stuff
there hey don't squish down a one plot
toilet paper so I am trying to cut back
a little the luxury the luxury feels
better when you've pushed yourself right
that's that's one thing you know I want
to have I've had a couple guys on my
podcast that were POWs in Vietnam right
oh really one of them was oh my god I
gotta listen to this more yeah so one of
them was shot down in Vietnam twice the
second time he got captured got captured
in South Vietnam
he was so they had to do the jungle
march up while he was in the jungle
March up he's he's caught in a two foot
tall bamboo cage in the middle of the
jungle and he's trying to get some sleep
his legs are shackled and he can't sleep
because the rats are coming and eating
the wounds knowing at the wounds on his
legs right
so his name is William reader Colonel
William meter just an amazing amazing
human being another guy named Charlie
plum captain Charlie plum he was shot
down last last flight of his first
deployment to Vietnam and he was shot
down captured put them in the Hanoi
Hilton for six years for six years it's
not a real Hilton though it's like a
does a joke no it's called the Hanoi
Hilton it was a prison camp okay yeah
it's a it's a it's the North Vietnamese
prison camp and you know for six years
eating nothing but like a ball of rice
every day having having nothing having
nothing did he say he misses it at all
in a weird way
he didn't say he missed it at all no but
what he did say is that the guys that
were in the Hanoi Hilton
they formed a bond that was so strong
that the rate of post-traumatic stress
disorder I was was minuscule compared to
the regular military the regular guys
that were out fighting the whole time
they just formed this incredible bond
POWs the POWs formed an incredible bond
and supported each other so well in that
prison camp
that when they came back they felt like
good the other thing that's interesting
is they when they came back they had a
huge hero's welcome and and that is you
know I was thinking about this because I
read a book by another Vietnam veteran
and this is a horrible story but this
guy he he lost both of his legs and you
know part of his hands and and when he
when the and he came back from Vietnam
and so now he's recovering for months
and months and years trying to stay
alive and he's watching on the news when
the POWs came home and they're getting
this big ticker tape parade well
deserved of course but here he is you
know alone in a hospital room with no no
enough celebration of any kind and it's
it's an awful awful story and that that
story as a matter of fact uh you know I
I did a series of podcast that's plumb
you said no so this is a guy named Lewis
polar and what's interesting about Lewis
polar and I'd I did a series of podcasts
three podcasts the first one was podcast
number 121 was about a guy named chesty
puller chesty puller is hands-down the
most famous marine of all time u.s.
marine of all time the to this day the
Marine Corps has a mascot it's a bulldog
and the and the Bulldogs name is chesty
right now they're on like chesty 17 or
something like that he's some of the
reigns probably eaten some of the testes
I've seen some of the five the five Navy
crosses this guy was just an incredible
incredible hero performed valiantly over
and over again on the battlefield and
was in World War two in Korea and just
just known as he's the guy that you know
he said things like oh we're surrounded
good now we know where they are you know
he's though he's that guy and he's this
the most famous marine ever so he had
one son his son was named Louis puller
and his son was you know raised and
learned how to shoot when he was six or
seven years old and he ended up calling
the Marine Corps but he was a little bit
of a different character right he was a
softer character he was a nicer guy he
he had glasses he was more more of a
more of an a-c a cerebral type guy but
you know his dad
Marine Corps and he decided you know
what okay I'm going to Marine corner
this is now 1967 I believe should he
have chosen the Air Force's that were
saying you know the Air Force does
incredible things as well yeah but he
chose the Marine Corps like his dad and
so he goes to Marine Corps and you know
he's one of these guys that does the
basic school or an officer cannon school
in the basic school so he's whatever
nine months or something like that gets
twenty days leaving the knees of platoon
commander in Vietnam Wow
between commander in Vietnam that fast
yeah that fast because of because of who
he was or because of his abilities
because the Vietnam War oh it does the
Vietnam War was like okay guess what we
need we need junior officers why do we
need junior officers because our junior
officers are getting wounded and killed
at a very high rate so he goes he ends
up in Vietnam it's awful as he describes
what's going on they're going out
there's three areas that they're
rotating through and one of the areas
that they rotate through every time they
go into this area they lose a guy or
they get a guy wounded and then they
never see the enemy then I'm gonna see
the enemy so it'd be me saying hey I
want you to go to Whole Foods Whole
Foods and Vaughn's and Trader Joe's and
every time you go to Trader Joe's
you're gonna lose like a body part and
you don't even know why look like you
wouldn't want to do that anymore right
yeah these guys are doing that and
they're doing that and they're losing
guys and they're losing guys like this
coochie tunnels under the produce it's
um it's just yeah something like that I
guess so eventually he he ends up there
getting a big going this big operation
to try and clean out that area he gets
in contact with the enemy he's running
back to his guys and as he's running
back he hits a booby track ie D and it
just it just brutalizes him loses a leg
loses a other leg at the hip and it
loses bunch of hands and he's just a
disaster they don't think he's gonna
live he holds on he makes it back to
America and it goes through his trials
and by the way his wife was pregnant at
the time so he comes home she has the
baby and you know he you know at one
point in the book he says he's
recovering it takes years to recover
years and they're giving him prosthetic
and the prosthetics that you can see
when they're talent when he's
talking about the prospects like the
prosthetics we have now are much more
advanced this thing is like leather
strap around his torso and he can only
walk on flat surfaces and find that he
just can't do it but you know he can't
he can't even wipe himself right he
can't because of the way his hands are
deformed and it's just awful it's awful
and you know meanwhile his dad was a
hero was a hero and his his dad when his
dad sees him like he's describing his
dad as just he can't his dad can't even
talk his dad is just streaming tears at
his bedside when he sees him for the
first time it's it's horrible and he
makes it through this right he makes it
through this and he meanwhile gets
addicted to the painkillers gets
addicted to the booze goes down that
whole spiral once he's kind of recovered
he kind of goes down this whole spiral
finally sort of recovers from that he
runs for political office with these
handicaps and everything he runs for
political office as a Democrat sort of a
semi anti-war Democrat and he did some
some interviews that got him some really
negative press that he wasn't patriotic
I mean here's a guy that gave you know
so much and they're saying oh you don't
love America and he's running against
the guy that had not gone to Vietnam
who's a Republican a pro Vietnam
Republican guy that had his deferment
his draft deferment he didn't go to
Vietnam for whatever reason you know
whatever he'll write fraud problem he
allegedly had he couldn't go to Vietnam
and he and he loses so Louis puller
loses to this guy goes back down the
spiral of alcohol and drugs finally his
wife's like hey we're done like you need
to fix yourself you're done brings him
to rehab goes into rehab he recovers and
while he's coming through his recovery
they're building the Vietnam Wall right
the Vietnam Memorial Wall and he starts
to feel like hey there they're gonna
they're gonna recognize us for what we
did you know they're gonna they're gonna
they're gonna give us some credit for
what we did and they build that wall and
he's he's like he's into it right and
the book ends with him they they unveil
the law and he's like feeling like hey
we we got ours now we got our
recognition and that's kind of how the
book ends that he's gonna write this
book and that's what the book that
you're reading is this book it's called
fortunate son by Louis polar and then
the book ends but the book doesn't end
there the story doesn't end there
because Louis polar two or three years
later he falls out of his wheelchair he
breaks his hip and they bring him to the
hospital and they put him back on
painkillers and he starts drinking again
and he kills himself oh yeah and it's
it's such a horrible story and I went
when I did those two podcasts I myself
I'm not gonna do him unless I have
something else to talk to I don't want
to leave that thing out there and so I
brought enough another friend of mine
named Jake shik who's an another marine
who was really badly wounded and he man
he was close
going in that direction addicted to
drugs they put him on and like suicidal
and he came out of it and he has an
organization called xx to kill but you
know so there's there's real hard things
that people go through and and I think
that when you see people in those
stressful stressful situations it
reveals who they are like as people you
know and so do you so taking away from
that man yes can you if I mean what uh
you know life is such an equalizer in so
many ways man I mean to have a man whose
father had so much accolades right and
it would seem like and then have another
man his son and that would have not only
so many great amazing experiences but
also so many you know just put into the
put to the fire you know I mean the
struggles I can't even imagine you know
like you get imagine getting back like
the part you told me like imagine
getting back and you see your wife and
you're not even like you don't have all
your body part
you know man that would just kill me and
then you're about to have a son and he
has all his body parts and here you are
like you know just like I mean it's just
life is just such an equalizer when you
see guys like that who have lost who
have had you know physical sacrifices
impairments for their body do you feel
bad still being fully able capable like
is there any I don't feel bad I feel
thankful I feel blessed yeah and and
when I see the attitudes I had I had
another guy is it hard to see that as
yeah I can imagine man even saying that
we see that attitude of somebody who has
a positive attitude yeah when you see
Jake chick when you see I've had
multiple guys on my podcast that have
been severely wounded guy named Rob
Jones a guy named Rob Jones lost both of
his legs above the thigh I'm sorry above
the knee
he ran 31 marathons in 31 days Wow
31 marathons in 31 days yeah so like
when so it doesn't make me feel bad it
makes me feel inspired it makes me want
to make sure that I'm not being a [ __ ]
yeah cuz those guys those guys are out
there and they're charging on and
they're not looking down they're not
they're not asking for sympathy they're
out there getting after it and so we
should be - exactly should be and we
should feel and we shouldn't feel
ashamed that we're not but we should
feel like you say we should feel
inspired and we should you know wake up
and with some sense of gratitude that
here we are fully able-bodied and if we
just set in motion sometimes a foot a
step something somebody who doesn't even
have a foot anymore doesn't even have a
step and if we just do that that our
brain and just a lot of our listeners
struggle with the emo you know emotional
type of stuff you know but if we just do
that that our brains and our spirits
will follow yeah and sometimes I take a
little bit of flack for saying this but
but you gotta like get control of your
emotions yeah you got to like say okay
you know what this girl left me or this
job I lost or I had this happen to me
when I was a kid you got to say you know
what okay I'm not gonna let that
situation control me and I'm gonna I'm
gonna take control of my emotions and
I'm gonna move forward you got it you
got to assert yourself you know your
mind is stronger than those little
emotions that are running around inside
your head you can overpower them yeah I
can do it
and if you don't do it they're gonna run
wild and they don't deserve to yeah they
don't deserve they don't know what
they're doing they're just up there
making noise and going crazy and running
around and and calling things out it's
like no you stop
get control those emotions you've got to
do it sometimes and again a lot of
people say hey that's that's not it's
not easy for everyone I get that it's
not easy but man the alternative is like
just let your emotions run run
everything and run you into the dirt
don't don't let that happen man I go
ahead yeah I grab hold of them get
control and like you said starts taking
a step in the right direction that's
where it starts man I love that man I
love that and I need it's just so funny
man I you know I'm so happy to be here
in this right now in my life you know
like you know because yeah I'm just you
know ever since I got it in like you get
into the AAA program just a program just
something it helped me to start to
change my perspective yeah you know um
will it's a form of discipline right
yeah this is well you don't that's
that's I wrote another book called
discipline equals freedom when you put
some kind of discipline in your life
it's gonna it's gonna give you freedom
ultimately right like before when you
were addicted to whatever you were
addicted to you you're a slave to those
things that's what you were and so when
you put the discipline around those
things it gives you freedom and and it's
clear with that's a really clear example
but it's clear with anything like when
you if you're gonna spend all your money
you're gonna waste all your money you're
gonna end up a slave to to finances all
the time you're always gonna be worried
about hey can I can I make can I make
rent this month it's like no put
discipline around your spending put
discipline around your work habits put
discipline around how you invest your
money and save your money and that's
gonna give you more freedom in the long
run yes so the more discipline you put
in your life the better off you're gonna
end up the more freedom you're gonna
have is it hard for you to have like is
it hard for you to like relax a little
bit sometimes or no man is it hard for
you to let go like what's like it like
what's like uh something you would do
like what's a vacation you would take
like not in the Middle East with a gun
yeah I surf oh you do
i surf I play guitar no nice and Kelly
Slater supposed to come on here oh
really that's some point yeah should be
called never met him but we got on this
conversation about water on Instagram
yeah
a conversation about water I just I
don't know water kind of freaks me out
you know more of a land guy kind of yeah
and uh and he's like man water is okay
you know and that was kind of the gist
of there's a little more ya know I think
that'll be that'll be good but see
surfing is the same thing it kind of
gives you it's it's a mind I won't say
it's mindless but it's pretty mindless
when you're out there your your mind is
just kind of wandering it's like jujitsu
your mind is just kind of wandering and
you're you're letting your mind go I
play guitar you know I'd do that to
relax I go watch the sunset and play
guitar you know I live in San Diego it's
like guess what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
watch the sunset I'm gonna play some get
box yeah that's the national pastime
down there
how many drunk people think you are John
Cena I don't want to I would say I would
say a decent amount I guess I get called
out and I think he's younger than me
people say you look like John Cena I
would say he looks like me that's up
yeah yeah I wouldn't I mean I'm gonna
head probably I don't even know if I
would have known probably if I hadn't um
you know done some research and stuff
like that do you uh do you feel like
that we are getting weaker as a society
of men do you feel like that as I said
before there's some guys that are coming
up right now that are hard as nails I
see him in the you know when I go out
and I meet with the young military guys
right now they're hard as nails and
they're better than better than I ever
was they're they're learning faster they
learn more they understand everything
from the physical aspects of how to work
out better and how to be in better shape
and how to recover better they know all
that stuff better than than we did in my
generation they understand all the
tactics better because we've been at war
for so long they're getting taught
better so there's guys that are out
there that are better and stronger and
tougher then then I was right but at the
same time are there other people that
are getting pampered and getting their
hands held so much that they don't know
how to do anything for themselves yeah
you know that's where I ended up right
in those kids book I wrote I wrote a
couple kids books as well and nice we'll
share links to there that's awesome yeah
way the warrior kid it's like there's a
kid he doesn't know his times tables he
can't do any pull-ups he doesn't know
how to swim and he's getting picked on
school and last day of school comes
around and he's all sad and crying
because he's he ends up on the pull-up
bar and everyone's laughing at him
because he can't do any pull-ups and he
kind of runs away and goes behind the
library and starts crying and when that
happens he as he's going home he
remembers that his Uncle Jake is coming
to stay with him for the summer and his
Uncle Jake was in the SEAL Teams oh it
was a pedophile no no I'm not a lawman
not at all
uncle Jake's come come to stay with him
and his uncle Jake's you know says hey
you want to go play basketball tomorrow
you want to go for a swim what you want
to do and he's like well I I can't go
for a swim I my life's horrible and
explains all these problems he has and
uncle Jake says hey all these problems
we can get him fixed Wow
puts him on a workout program teaches
him how to study teaches him how to eat
right teaches him jiu-jitsu so he can
defend himself teaches him how to swim
puts him on the path that a lot of kids
don't don't have that right now and
teaches them the discipline is going to
give you freedom a lot of kids don't
have discipline and there's something
that happened I don't know what it was
it was between it's some generational
thing there's so many young men out
there who I think that are grasping
towards guys like you guys like Jordan
Pederson coming from a little bit of a
different perspective but you know guys
like Joe Rogan guys you know who we are
just bet like we are just empty with
some of that I don't know if it's a
parental thing I don't know what it is
but there's some and it's it's just I
see it everywhere and I hear about it a
lot it's a lot of men are and I think
that's what it is we did not learn any
discipline somehow yeah and I think also
it has a little bit to do with if you're
always being told if you won't let me
not not not always being told but if
you're never told hey it's okay to be
strong or it's good to be strong hey
it's good to be able to defend yourself
right hey it's good to get good grades
and kick ass in school it's better you
want to be smarter the idea that we
can't compete with each other I think is
has something to do with it to say hey
it's we don't want to compete with each
other like no actually you are going to
compete with people and and if you don't
think you're going to compete man you're
gonna have a hard life because life is
life is about competition and again does
this mean I've come
with everyone's I mean I'm like hey I'm
gonna get more downloads than feel right
I don't really care man I hope you get
more downloads than me but I'm competing
with you I'm competing with myself I
want to do a better job
that's what work that's what we're doing
right and it brings everybody up exactly
whereas if you get told all the time hey
you don't know being strong is bad
hey standing up for yourself is bad hey
if you have an opinion it's better if
you just accept everyone's opinion it's
like no actually you can have your own
opinion that's okay yeah and so I think
a combination of those things of I think
that ends up putting in in a certain
generation has put guys in a situation
where they they look up and they say
there's something in them that wants to
be a warrior right that wants to compete
that wants to fight that wants to win
but they've never been able to nurture
that thing right it's never been given
any water right and not even been
allowed to even kind of peak its head
around exactly because because because a
mom or dad saying no no it's it's okay
everyone's a winner yeah no actually you
feel it right you you use the game and
you're like man I'm a loser and someone
says no no it's okay you still a winner
you don't feel that way that Sherman's a
[ __ ] loser brother I remember this
one dude and this dude one time they had
this kid in art school named Sherman
right he was a [ __ ] loser bro and he
wasn't probably really up well everybody
thought he's literally lost everything
dude and then one day the last day of
school I think in fourth grade he
somehow got some boom boxes and put him
in the cafeteria right and turned them
all on the Michael Jackson right this
was the most ginger kid he was so
transparent you could see him being
alive you could see all of his organs
right I mean just completely pale and he
[ __ ] did the entire Michael Jackson
dance on the tables and just blew the
entire universe open right and after
that I don't know what how I think about
it went directly to the moon like he was
just a straight champion after that but
yeah I mean it's like I think there's
also a thing yet so I think it's that
everybody's the same there's this thing
that it's it's not okay to be different
or to like open up your mouth if you
have a different perspective even
because then you at least you learn to
be wrong you learn to be right you learn
to like oh well maybe I am this way or
maybe I'm more this way you know I think
also there's a lot of things where a lot
of parents aren't a lot of discipline
their kids and so a lot of kids don't
feel you know young people fee
more like our parents feel I think more
like they're not allowed to kind of
discipline you know like when I was
growing up you got spanked I'm her mom
my buddy's mom would beat my ass all the
time like I'm a [ __ ] notice lady you
know but she would whup my ass and I'm
so grateful that she did it was it was
something I mean I still can feel
sometimes that hand hitting my you know
my thighs you know but I think there's
definitely a discipline a discipline
thing that goes on out there
I have one other question then we have
some fans that called him with questions
for you
Ron uh do you there's a lot of PTSD now
there's a lot of stuff that happens it
wouldn't men are in the military and um
oh I had this question - did you ever
were there ever an instance where you
tried to get yourself captured so you
could be a Pio w no I did not try that I
Dennis and I don't even know well first
of all there wasn't any such thing like
they were gonna cut your head off there
wasn't like hey you're gonna learn to
capture you and we're gonna hang on to
you like no they're gonna get you there
in a torture you to cut your head off
but now that's that's not even a it's
not a consideration right yeah I just
wonder I guess if you meet some of these
other men with like you know that have
had such extreme instances just part of
you as that you know as that you know as
that battler does that battle are in you
almost do you want to get tested
absolutely yeah is that is that an
extreme test yes is that probably the
most extreme test it's definitely one of
them but you know no I never never
thought about that for a million years
Christmas wish-list
no not on any kind of list whatsoever um
do there's a lot of the stuff with PTSD
there's a lot of people that claim that
a lot of other men are like claim Peter
and women or people are claiming pts
like there's a lot of like a scam like
with ensuring you know like people
getting money do you do you feel like
that is putting like a bad gloss on men
that are actually suffering do you hear
anything about that well there's there's
I would say that there's probably a
portion of people that claim to have
PTSD and don't really have any good
reason for PTSD and I'd say there's a
lot of guys that say that they don't
have PTSD and actually do have some PTSD
so it's a brain Mets
there's a lot of guys that don't want to
admit to it that but I think we're
getting better about that as we get
better about saying hey it's okay if
you've got PTSD a lot of people go oh is
it okay well then I guess I had PTSD too
or I have PTSD too so I would say
there's some of that out there and I
think I'm not quite sure what to do
about that or how to handle that but I
think that guys for me you know when I
meet a guy that's been through a lot you
know I just want to help him out yeah
whatever whatever way we can to make
sure that they are getting the help that
they need and if we help some people
that don't really need it okay I mean
that's that's that might be the the
sacrifice that we make mm-hmm that's a
good way to look at it would you ever um
would you ever have to be deployed again
or no no cuz I retired he did yeah but
if [ __ ] hit the fan can we count on you
I'd be back too right ready to rock and
roll that's cool you know I went to know
the serious answer that isn't fully
retired so unless we get like level 9
World War 3 going on I probably won't be
participating and to more important than
that there's plenty of guys in in the
military right now that are way better
than me and they got it handled yeah
yeah man I went to UM you know over the
years I did some different just going
and doing some service of we went to
Iraq one time or can't it went to Arif
John one time when we went to that it's
like a base for somewhere people laying
and a lot of planes land I think it's in
Saudi Arabia maybe but they had a moment
where there's this alarm that goes off
if something comes into the base and
then everybody's just kind of standing
there and you're waiting to see like if
something is gonna blow the [ __ ]
building off yeah yeah yeah and it was
like it bros the craziest thing I didn't
know and I'd never been around it were
you in a bunker did you get did they get
you into a bunker of some kind no we
were I was actually in the gym and and
it just went off I guess something that
come over one of the fences is alarm and
it was just one of the most scariest
things that I'd never heard yes and been
a part of because basically then when I
was waiting for 30 seconds to see if I
was gonna be alive it was like a really
shitty game show kinda yeah so so that
sucks
and then like I've been in a couple
situations where I was getting mortared
and you but I've actually heard mortar
launches so now you know they're coming
and you don't know and it's just a it's
just a roll the dice at that point but
then again that's like your shaking head
like oh my god that that's nothing
compared to like when we were talking
about earlier about World War one where
these guys were taking that sustained
bombardment of massive like I'm talking
about oh I had nine mortars shot at me
these guys had tens if not hundreds of
thousands of artillery rounds fired at
them there was millions of rounds like
before the I think was the Battle of the
Somme before the Battle of Somme they
fired 1.6 million rounds at the enemy
before they started so we're talking to
a whole nother level and that's why you
see guys go watch some World War to
World War 1 videos on shell-shocked it's
what's one of the most horrible things
you can see and it also shows you how
fragile the human mind is and that
there's guys that would go blind they
there's nothing wrong they never got hit
but they would go blind or they'd go
deaf or they'd go mute because their
mind would just completely shut down
when they couldn't control their body
anymore it's it's a horrible thing so
I'm glad you got to experience one
one-millionth of a fraction of a percent
of that when you were in Saudi Arabia no
and the horn went off and and but
seriously take that take that action of
a second and use multiply it infinitely
and that's that's what these guys
experienced I can't even imagine what
these guys I mean I can't even fathom is
it is it so loud that you can't think or
does that start is that like how it is
the first couple of times you hear like
some explosions and then it starts to
adjust you know it's weird your mind
does some things when there's situations
going on that I'm sure you've heard this
before that things slowed you've been a
car accident and things slow down to
things slow down yes yeah so there's
that there's also some selective hearing
that starts to take place where you can
hear things like a voice that you might
not normally here because there's loud
gunfire or whatever so there's some
things that your mind does in that
survival mode that are very effective
and make you a little bit more ready to
to handle a situation at hand do you
start to have your faith adjust as you
went through experiences like that like
did you have any was there anything like
that that kind of had
and for you you know for me my new sort
of like my patriotism like it is what it
is it was what it was it's it's does it
get strengthened like I'll tell you the
thing that strengthened me more than
anything is is from a faith perspective
is like you get to see guys that put
their friends above themselves Wow
and and and you know I guys that put
their their own lives their friends
lives above their own lives and when you
see that is it pretty incredible if
there's an there's there's a you know
maybe it's not a doctrinal religious
element to that but there is a there is
a deeply spiritual thing when someone
says you know what I'm gonna make sure
and and you know this this happened with
one of my guys named Mike Mansoor um you
know there was a grenade thrown onto a
roof and there was three guys up there
with him and he jumped on that grenade
and and he sacrificed his life for his
friends and if that's not a
of spirituality and belief and he was a
very faithful guy he was a believer in
God and you know I think that with
seeing that and knowing that with you
know just understanding that that can
happen and that that's that's a religion
unto its own the way that we treat each
other in the sacrifice we can make for
each other there's a there's a religion
right there kind of that's powerful man
yeah thanks for sharing some of those
thoughts yeah I'd love to get in a few
questions here Nick if we have some
totally and I had a question too okay
how do you prioritize and the military
like Russia as a threat in comparison to
some of the other people were battling
cuz in the news it's huge so
I think that I think that if I think
that we have to we have to consider all
threats right and I think that we need
to consider all threats as viable
threats and I think the best way to keep
viable threats at bay
is by being as strong and powerful as we
possibly can and to have the world know
that if someone gets out of line we will
handle that problem and I think that's
the best way to avoid having to handle
those problems and if someone's
listening they think oh you're a
warmonger and you you know what you just
said is hey we should go out and just
start smashing people no actually it's
the opposite is what I believe I believe
I don't you know when I say this all the
time the folks the people that have been
to war were the last people that want to
go to war cuz we know who's going we
know it's our friends and we know what
happens and we know that it's not it's
gonna destroy lives and people are gonna
get maimed and killed and families are
gonna be left without fathers and sons
it's awful and so I'm the last person
that's saying hey we should go to war
but I believe that the best way to avoid
going to war with Russia with Iran is to
be strong and powerful and have people
know and have the world know that if
someone wants to test us someone wants
to push us beyond what we believe to be
fair we will we will handle that problem
and we will handle it strong quick
judiciously but at the same time we'll
handle it with enough force that we
won't have to worry about that problem
again word okay so our first voice man
our first voice mail we had a caller
come in and asked Theo who you'd want to
spend dinner with and then we put it
back out to the listeners and we thought
we'd get a lot of historical historical
figures celebrities but one guy kind of
went a different way with it and we want
to see what you think
dear Jim from Pittsburgh who I would
have lunch with in 2005 I was in Iraq
and I got injured twice the first time
somebody logged a couple mortars in and
for a longest time I was just so angry
and had full of hatred but I really
started thinking about it and I would
like to have lunch with that guy I mean
at that time it hurt me hurt five other
Marines but I want to figure out why
just talk to him and hear his side hear
his point of view you know the some
radical guy that's brainwashed or some
guy that just trying to protect his home
and his children and felt this was the
way he had to do it thanks brother cool
love your stuff you're killing it man
yeah I think that that's that's pretty
cool that's a pretty cool statement and
is that a normal thing sometimes they to
wonder who's over there uh I don't know
if that's a normal thing to wonder who's
over there you know we got to see him
you know right so a lot of these guys he
said there was some real so so we knew
who we were dealing with and you know
it's interesting you know that guy
captain plumb that I talked about that
was in in the Hanoi Hilton for six years
he went back there you know and he went
there and it's you know there's
propaganda and they make it seem like
the prisoners were treated well and all
the stuff which is complete lies but it
didn't really like change his viewpoint
anything right you know that so I think
that that's a that's a great statement I
wish that guy could get you know I would
love for him to be able to sit down with
whoever lobbed those mortars at him and
I think to his point he was asking or he
stated is it a guy that was radical or
is it some guy that was just I would say
it was either some guy that was radical
like he said or some guy that was
getting paid 50 bucks by the by the
insurgents to go and lobbies mortars Wow
and to me it could be either one of
those and and that's the thing about war
man war doesn't care it you know that
the name that has your as your your the
bullet that has your name on it
the bullet doesn't have a name on it yes
says to whom it may concern and Wow and
that's the way it is do you find it like
I was just in China to that guy by the
way thanks for your service
brother yeah do I find it interesting
like I was just in China a few weeks ago
and you can't get citizenship in China
like you can't like it seems like
there's a lot of countries that like
they're not super welcoming of uh you
know like they're not unwelcoming but
they're it's not like this open-door
policy that sometimes we seem to have in
America and I know that's kind of what
defines America in a way is that we have
a place where people can you know we
have kind of a place where people can
come to and feel welcome you know but
then sometimes I start to like our
country starting to turn into a [ __ ]
Airport where it's just like at the
Atlanta Airport just forever it's like
this huge layover for everybody when
yeah I don't know sometimes I want to
feel I want to be okay saying I'm an
American without feeling like I'm a bad
person I figured something like that
that's going on in the ether these days
you come and hang out with me and my
friends you can say that all day and you
won't seem like a bad person
any of us thanks brother I appreciate
that
let's get another uh let's get two more
Nick hi this is Austin with a question
for Jocko willing I just want to help is
anywhere I can listen year old punk band
rage of discipline you brought up on the
Joe Rogan show I've been looking for it
but can't find it the information would
be helpful thanks a lot
love your work do you ever play with
Kyle Turley did you guys ever cross
paths I don't know no don't know who
that is
who's Kyle Turley he's uh he's an
offensive lineman for the Rams and and
he had a punk band and he also served in
the military yeah so I wasn't when I was
a kid like I said was a real rebellious
kid and we were always in bands now the
band's meant you know we're gonna go
into my shed and make noise I felt like
we were out on tour or anything like
that but we did we did go in the studio
one time and we uh we we put down some
tracks I think we put down like twelve
or fifteen tracks and my my bro who was
in the band with me who's now a guy up
in LA Elgin James he's actually a writer
he's a writer and he's he's got his own
cool story you could have him on the
podcast yeah I'd love to we'll reach out
to him yeah he's um
he anyways I went in the military and he
ended up joining gang and kind of
getting crazy for a while and ended up
in federal prison for a little bit and
in the meantime he had broken away from
that scene and went to
got started making movies and he made a
movie he made a little short movie got
invited to the Sundance Film Festival or
the Sundance Film Lab and he learned how
to how to make movies he ended up doing
a great movie called little birds and
now he there's a new program you ever
heard of sons of anarchy yeah so there's
a spinoff from sons of anarchy
it's called Mayans MC it's about a
Mexican motorcycle gang and anyways he's
Natisha yeah oh wow so he's writing that
thing interesting but but yeah when we
were kids me and him we're getting our
rock-and-roll on hardcore music and we
have the original what are they called
reel-to-reel tapes and we were just
talking about is reel-to-reel tapes is
like back in the day when in a recording
studio when they got all these different
tracks and so you need a thicker tape to
record all the tracks and so you have
these big like reels like a movie like a
lot a wall or something yes so he's got
the tracks and we're finding a place
right now that can take those tracks and
and and burn them down onto a release a
couple yeah we're gonna get it real
we got like I think we got three songs
that are salvageable that would be worth
throwing out there so so yeah we'll do
it man we'll put out there and that
could be a new weapon that we would
change the name of the band like every
like six weeks or whatever because you
know we take no we're going in the new
direction right because we took
ourselves super seriously and so the the
the kind of the iconic name of the band
was Bronson's children after Charles
Bronson and we had these cool shirts
that had a picture of Charles Bronson
they had Bronson's children like little
kids riding on it and and sewed oh yeah
yeah so so I actually I actually
reprinted those and I and I sell them so
people people are representing the
Bronson's children at all so when I'm
bringing it back out yeah rage of
discipline was the name of the band for
a little while was rage discipline we
were called struggle we were called lock
and load we had all kinds of names man
you know we'd have like internal issues
about the direction and artistic control
you know it is when you're 14 and just
playing in a punk rock band
you're really just loud in the garage oh
yeah it's definitely loud at the garage
there's no doubt about that it's a
reminds me of um have you ever had Henry
Rollins on I haven't but the interesting
thing about interesting man yeah yeah so
when I was a kid I was way into black
flag which was you know where he
originally played who's the vocalist got
brought into black flag but so I went on
tour with when he went when he left
Black Flag he put out some albums of his
own in the beginning they were called it
was called Rollins band the first one
was called Henry out of Collins but then
he the next one was called life time
this is a great album and when that
album came out me and all my friends
from Bronson's children we wouldn't on
tour and we would go to every show he'd
play me I put we probably went to like
ten shows but we'd saw my peers yeah
yeah yeah
and it's that the cool thing is this is
back in the day where you know we go to
CBGB's and show up at you know three
o'clock in the afternoon help him
offload all their gear help them get
their gear set up as much as we could
hang out and it was it was like it was
nothing man it's kind of like what the
UFC used to be like when you just hang
out with all the fighters we just be
hanging out with everyone everyone's
cool and so did that with Rollins
probably like I said it probably went to
ten probably ten shows but I saw him a
bunch at a bunch by probably something
five other times or eight other times
besides that and you know when I was a
kid Rollins was this kind of like bigger
than life kind of yeah cuz he was but
he's about ten years older than me
and you know he you know he has like
Search and Destroy tattooed on his back
and he's like you know all hardcore and
you know that definitely influenced me
when I was a kid you know cuz I was like
13 14 or 13 that was your next band oh
yeah for sure and and there's a there's
an album called Black Flag my war and if
you listen to my war side too it's this
really slow as at first it was a first
kind of like really slow and heavy music
that started to mix the hardcore in the
punk with Black Sabbath into one and so
when I was a kid that album side two of
that album stayed on my record plan for
like a year straight just play that over
and over again but and then so then I
joined the military because I knew
that's what I always wanted to do
and when uh it was probably 1992
whenever the first Lollapalooza remember
lalala - Rollins was playing
Lollapalooza and I I went and I didn't
have tickets or anything but I figured
if I could just get like hook up with
him he'd let me in cuz because you'd
seen him so many times
like we'd seen him in like the you know
we would hang out you know not like Bros
right but you know hey man he's he's 26
at the time right I'm 16 you know that's
that's it so he's looking at me like hey
man this guy's one of my one of my one
of my young people or whatever yeah and
so then fast forward a few years
whatever it is and I went to
Lollapalooza and I you know I was pretty
good when I was a kid at sneaking around
and figuring stuff over ah yeah covert
operations and I finally I got to him
and he he looked at me like he
recognized me who knows you know what I
mean I meet a lot he's meeting a lot of
people over the years but like I said
you know we were he might recognize me
who knows but I was like hey man I you
know I went on tour the lifetime tour 80
whatever it was 86 or something 89 8 or
88 when I wasn't bleep it's like 86
sound and he goes oh yeah man what's up
and I was okay man any chance you could
get us in you know get me my boy here
and I had some other kid that was in the
SEAL Teams with me that was a hardcore
kid and he I just remember him saying he
goes man to be easier to get you into
Fort Knox right now they got this place
on lockdown and and he was cool and that
was that then I saw him a couple years
later at a Cypress Hill I think he was
hell on the Beastie Boys and Rollins and
saw him and so that was that and so to
answer your question to have I had him
on the podcast the answer's no I haven't
had him on the podcast I talked about
him on one of the early podcast somebody
asked me about him and you know I kind
of talked about the fact that you know
when I was a kid hey man this guy was
like super hardcore and you know that's
that he had an influence on me when I
was younger and then you know as I got
older you know and I started I was you
know like he had search-and-destroy
tattooed on his back and like I was
doing Search and Destroy missions right
so there was a do you think you're
living at his tattoos yeah a little bit
and but it'd be interesting I definitely
would like to sit down to talk I'd like
to find out if he really actually
remembers us yeah he because he might
because he's a smart man yeah Ariela
sure for sure and you know it's I the
guy had a and that band had a big
influence on baby's influence that it
feels a lot of people yeah yeah did you
did you like the kind of music growing
up no I would go to a Cypress Hill um I
went on that tour actually he [ __ ]
hit this hot girl with my car in the
park and I still feel bad about it a
little bit she was hot but did you
injure her you know what does everybody
have their different definition I think
of what in it did you have to bring her
to the hospital
look we didn't have to bro we were
running late oh yeah but I think
somebody might have those are all that
stuff we were talking earlier about
being a good person I'm doing the world
I guess this was pre field this was a
high yeah high school this is hot
literally I guess you know that's
another thing like I had these guys on
my on my podcast I had this podcast with
Captain plum and I had another guy who
was in World War two there was a fighter
pilot World War two and he got shot down
in France Oh in France and aw I hate the
French yeah just like crazy this is when
you know we were trying to help them but
right and then these guys start saying
like well you know we try and uphold the
Warrior Ethos and and doing good things
in life like you do Jocko and I was like
man don't put me in the same category
yes you guys because these guys are like
this you know I was like like you know a
little kid running around like a like an
idiot when I was younger so do you still
feel like a kid do you feel like an
organized kid what do you feel like it's
weird cuz uh part of me still feels like
I'm 14 you know what I mean part of me
just is still excited to get up and just
get crazy and do stuff like I was maybe
like two years ago you know the beach
cruiser is about yeah so you know I
lived down by the beach but there's a
little hill and I was on my beach
cruiser and I was going down this hill
and I had to make a left and there was
like oncoming traffic and incoming what
do you guys call that just traffic
that's heading towards me okay yeah it
was like a military term for it yeah
well incoming okay
incoming is when
Browns like artillery rounds coming
towards you yes when that siren went off
when you learned Saudi Arabia that was
to indicate incoming rounds well at
least I assume that's what it was right
but yeah this is just oncoming traffic
okay and I'm done biking and I'm like in
back of my mind I'm like I think I can
make this right and so I do I pick up
speed and I cut the car off and he honks
and I pull up and I made it you know and
I'm just thinking you know like that's
the fourteen-year-old kid that just
still will slip out at some times and
just do something stupid but and that's
why it's like a miracle that that you
know that I'm alive that you're alive
because you think about the dumb stuff
you did when you were 13 14 15 years old
I mean we're talking ignorant stuff oh
yeah and so so poor so part of me still
feels like that and part of me feels
older and I guess you said the word
organized yeah I'd say I'm more
organized and and just as you get older
and you learn more and you start to get
better perspective on on life and it's
the stuff that you you know that you
just never listen to and you're a kid
with a kid like my dad would tell me
something and I'd just be like would and
this guy doesn't know what the hell yeah
I do you know and you're just it's just
cuz you're dumb yeah and so as much as
you want to
then that's well that's more like the
kids books that I wrote it's like it's
good for somebody to hear it from a
different angle and I get all kinds of
dads you know that'll say hey thanks for
saying this you know it's the same stuff
I've been saying but the kids listening
now you know what I mean
people don't listen to their parents a
lot of times because you got to build up
some kind of rebellion against your
parents so that when it comes time to
leave you can do it you can do it easily
right like if that's interesting it's a
necessity it's a necessity you have to
you know you're gonna leave the nest so
you have to try and figure out how you
gonna break away so if you're just we're
always doing whatever your mom and dad
said and you were their little puppy
well then when it comes time to go out
and hunt on your own you're not gonna be
able to do it so there's something
that's genetically programmed into you
to start to rebel against those parents
that are pushing the envelope and that's
what I did like when I joined the Navy I
told my dad I was like hey I just joined
the Navy like I thought it was like I
thought I was like a 40 year old man I
just joined the Navy and he says oh he
says you're gonna hate it
Wow and I said why do you think I'm
gonna hate it he says cuz you don't like
Authority and don't listen to anyone
else
you know like now I was like hey I'm
going in the SEAL Teams you know it's a
team and I was that which is just stupid
cuz in the SEAL Teams guess what you
have bosses and you have officers and
you have chiefs and you got to do you
know you've got to you got to carry the
line you got a tow line there you do
have more you do have more influence
right in the SEAL Teams like those
influence up and down the chain of
command and we're all bros but at the
same time you know it's a got a mission
to carry out you gonna you can go get it
was it hard for you to learn to take at
to take direction I'm finding that
that's someone in my life I have to
tough time with sometimes but I know
that it's probably better because anyway
yeah what was it hard for you to learn
that at any point well here's what I did
so yeah my dad was 100% right like I
don't like Authority I don't like listen
to people that's why I was running
around in a [ __ ] hardcore punk rock
band when I was 13 years old but that's
that's why yeah it's nutsack yeah yeah
that's one of the many days yeah and and
and what I did to try and to try and get
around that is I just I just started
saying okay whatever someone's gonna
have to tell me to I mean it's gonna do
it beforehand so like I was a radio man
my first platoon and so that means you
got to prepare all these radios and you
got a waterproof the radios and you got
to set up a communications plan and as
soon as I realize that's what I was
gonna get told to do I just started
doing it and so when my boss would come
in hey you got to do something right
it's already done so you want to tell me
what to do because I I already did it so
that was sort of my way of getting
around it and then I continued to do
that was always trying to stay a step
ahead and make make just a I have a step
ahead of my boss so I wasn't getting
told what to do because I didn't like it
and then as I got older I was like oh
you know why they're telling me what to
do cause it's gonna help us as a team
and that's okay so I got to put my
rebellious nests in check a little bit
as I got a little bit older
mm-hmm do you have children or no I do
have four children do you really yeah
yeah that's crazy
you know I think you could sell your
sperm on the internet dude honestly or
like at one of those farms like those
bull things you know yeah dude oh I bet
a farmer with somebody a farmer
oh dude somebody pay probably 40 grand
for a half a gallon a bit yeah I hear
you do you love being a father is it
awesome it's awesome yeah it's awesome
did you think it would be that cool was
it unique was it different to you
does it do you feel like a does it have
do you feel like a commander at all is
there any similarities and there's that
similarities but there's that there's
the key difference between being a dad
and being a leader in a CEO platoon is
there's there's one there's one level
okay so when you're in a seal platoon
and you're in charge of a seal platoon
you love your guys
I mean you that's that's your you love
your guys you want to take care of them
they're your number one priority and I
didn't think that that feeling could
ever get any stronger Wow but when you
have kids there's one level more of
emotion and the level more of emotion
that you have is that there you want
nothing more in life than for them to be
successful right you want them and this
is what makes it hard because when
you're a dad and you're 47 years old
you're looking at your kids like listen
kid if you do this right here it's gonna
put you on the right path and and and
then when they don't want to do it
you're like no you want to beat it into
him here's the problem if you try and
beat it into him they're gonna rebel
against it even harder I had a book I
have a neighbor and my middle daughter
who's a who's a badass right she's a
wrestler she's a she's just strong oh
she could probably burn his job I think
yeah for sure yeah and so she's she but
at a certain age she was doing
cheerleading right and so I just was
like okay you're gonna do cheerleading
and there's great athleticism and
Cheerilee yeah you know but there's also
like some stuff about cheerleading with
the hair and the all this makeup and all
this stuff and so it's not exactly like
the number one thing I wanted my
daughter to do I know they get a lot of
confidence out of it there's some real
positives to it I don't want to talk
about about it but it's not something I
was super fired up but my neighbor goes
he's on where's your daughter I said oh
she's you know she's at cheerleading and
he goes all you let her do that oh and I
said well I do so she doesn't come home
with like a tattoo on a forehead right
cuz that's what happens if right and
eventually she said she didn't want to
she wanted to focus on wrestling and and
knowledge you had to kind of stand there
and right now if I would have in my mind
if I would have forced her and said no
you're not allowed to do that she would
have either just done it even more or
she would have rebelled against me in a
in a bad bad way where all of a sudden
you know she's doing things that are
really outside the box and that's I
always tell me when you got kids like
you got to keep them in the box but you
want to give them a nice big box right
your kids a lot of parents they think
that their kids are gonna be who they
want them to be like who who you who you
want your kid to be is who they're gonna
be and that's not gonna happen I'm not
gonna here to break the news to you you
they're gonna you want to keep them in a
box now if they get so far out of the
box that it's gonna disrupt their life
or ruin their life like they're gonna go
to jail they start doing stuff like that
obviously it out another something's
gonna hurt their health really bad you
got to pull them back inside the box and
you got to find a way to do it that they
don't rebel even harder against you
and I think my parents to their credit
gave me enough leeway because believe me
I push the envelope on leeway yeah I
mean with Satan's not sack and so they
gave me enough leeway I think to to
where I didn't when I got to the edges I
came back on my own you know what I mean
and I think that's the proper way to do
it if you can
right it's hard to walk that line it's
awesome man and we have any more
tournament for is good I would my wife
told me to no more children as my wife
told me yeah so and where'd you meet
your wife at I'm at what my wife
oversees actually oh yeah her overseas
yeah she's a Brit my wife's a Brit oh
wow yeah crazy man really I think I mean
I've always had issues with the Patriots
my favorite movie aim small miss small
yeah okay what's the movie that you
watched like what's like a funny movie
you would enjoy that you like Oh I mean
Big Lebowski you know it's right there
at the top of as far as funny movies I
think The Big Lebowski is I don't even
know if there's any company is there
competition against Big Lebowski I don't
know that's a good one that's a
notorious when movies aren't that great
anymore that's what I kind of feel do
you um are there any war movies that you
watch that really kind of set some of it
in no place the Pacific which is the
miniseries that was on HBO the Pacific
was the one that's about the Pacific
Theatre and then Band of Brothers is the
same thing but it's about the European
theater theater it's about dick winners
and they're both they're both amazing
and there's a bunch they're both based
on books and actually the Pacific is
both based on a whole bunch of books and
I've actually covered I think every one
of those books on my podcast as it goes
into way more detail in the books
and so yeah those are those are two I
think of of the best portrayals that
I've seen do you ever read that the
things they carried you know what I'm
talking about
oh yeah absolutely I covered that book
on my podcast Wow yeah awfully long I'm
gonna start with that episode man I love
that okay yeah yeah the episode the
podcast yeah and it is and that's sort
of a semi-fictional book and he ended up
writing another book that's that's not
as fictional but yeah it's a great book
for sure yeah a lot of love that
thinking of all the things when you go
into battle and you're in battle and
that sort of thing is any of that like
in the morning before at night when
you're like it or there moment are you
thinking ice are some of those things
kind of milling around inside of you
you retsoor what's kind of steaming up
is there anything beyond this is
something that you know life who wrote
extreme ownership with me and who is the
owner of the company with me of national
in front with me
we'd ask questions like that and we
always say the same thing which is maybe
you're so busy yeah especially like we
you know he was a platoon commander I
was the tasking to commander when we
were going on an operation it was like
we were so busy getting ready for that
operation there wasn't time - people
would ask like what was your pump up
music and I'm like you talking about we
were sitting around listen to music like
we were rounding up deconfliction plans
and going through the brief and making
sure no new Intel came in and making
sure our gear was squared away and
getting them making sure the brief was
on I mean that's what we were doing so
we weren't sitting around thinking about
like anything I'm gonna worry yeah you
know and that's that comes back to what
we talked about earlier if just like
being 100% focus like people did that go
did you miss your family like I wasn't
even thinking about my family I know at
that time I had wife and three kids at
home I wasn't thinking about my wife and
three kids I was thinking about like
okay I that's what I'm thinking about
right is the situation that we're in and
how are we gonna get through it yeah and
it doesn't mean that you're not thinking
about them the love you have for them
though you guys all experience this
baked into you but right now it's it's
go time you have focus you have your
friends you have your you have your your
group your unit you have to take care of
yeah your own little band your band of
brothers out there and this fascinating
man it's inspiring and I really love the
part about if we can't serve that we can
still serve our country by utilizing the
freedoms and the gifts that we have here
I think it's fascinating
jacoub willing thank you so much man
we're gonna put all your stuff at the
beginning of the episode Nick was there
anything else you wanted to get in was
there any other questions
one super quick question I think's
really actionable advice I think you
could probably answer pretty quick okay
great
hey how's it goin deal what's up Jack oh
this is Brandon from Las Vegas my
question for Jacko is uh in your opinion
what's the best weapon for home defense
and what kind of music do you listen to
just the first part
yeah I mean the best weapon for home
defense first of all you got to make
sure if you're gonna get a weapon for
home defense you got to make sure you
train with it and what you feel
comfortable with a lot of people will
say a shotgun the noise that a shotgun
makes is enough to just just the the
cocking of a shotgun right when you jack
the slide on a shotgun it goes Shh most
criminals are gonna run if they're smart
as soon as they hear that noise so a
shotgun is a great weapon it's a it's an
easy to shoot weapon but at the same
time you know and then you got handguns
if you need something quick but the
biggest thing with both those is you
have to train you have to train to use
them and getting a weapon and not
training to use it is is is dumb so if
you're gonna get a weapon which
definitely if you if you've got a home
and you live in an area where you can
come under threat you should be able to
protect your home and you should get a
weapon and if you get a weapon whether
it's a pistol whether it's a shotgun
learn to use it and and keep it in a lot
in a safe place
you know in a place where you only you
can access it you can access it quickly
if you need it but where the
neighborhood kid can't break into your
house and start feeling with your gun
and shoot themselves you know it's a
it's a real big responsibility that
responsible adults should be able to
take on but yeah do some research go go
tries to shooting some different weapons
see which ones you like talk to the
professionals where you shoot your gun
and get a good opinion from them because
it's very uh it's a matter of opinion in
many ways might be best and depends on
what you're where do you live what's the
house made out of you know if you got
concrete walls you got plaster walls
what's we got to analyze your situation
a little bit yeah nobody yet but
definitely learn to use it not be
knowledgeable of it if it is a
responsibility treat it like one
absolutely yeah no mum he's a wooden
spoon I think ya know and I when you
were talking about someone else's mom
beatin your ass I was laughing because
that's
i-i've been smacked with a wooden spoon
from someone else's mom but I had the
same reaction as you like wait I even
know this lady
I don't crack admit she's keeping it in
line but we were making too much noise
eleven o'clock at night or whatever and
other kids trying to sleep you know what
shut it down to crack that's gonna be
one of our next books that's gonna be
the title this episode I think Jocko
needs a crack Jacko willing man thank
you so much for your service and thank
you so much for the inspiration I think
that you do that you know just trying to
lead by example you know being a father
being a a businessman being someone who
just continues to attack life on the
daily and even if you do every now and
then take a little bit of a break a
small one a luxury moment luxury moment
but we're you know there's a lot of guys
are grateful for the inspiration so
thank you very much make sure I'm your
own brother yeah man let's go rush all
up in them huh
[Music]
I thought it's gonna take
little town for me to set that parking
brake can lift myself all my shine
[Music]